I have scaffolded an empty function here called update,
which takes as a single argument the year which we elect to update the map with.
In order to update our map for a single year,
we need to perform the following steps.
First, we will be filtering our data for
the given year that we pass to our update function.
And once we filter our data we need to remove any elements on our
map which no longer belong there.
And the last piece of our update function is to add any new elements on
the page that weren't already on their before the update.
In D3 we'll be filtering our data with its built in filter function,
then select the given year we want to plot.
To find any elements to remove, we'll be using the special exit selection
after the data bind, and to add any new elements for a given year.
We'll use the familiar enter selection and
the last bit that we haven't talked about yet.
But an additional feature I want to add is to only show
the countries that are participating in the World Cup for the given year.
Now let's see what all of these functions might look like in d3.